[Musik]
wir dürfen in Kooperation mit dem
Bildungsministerium 21 Referenten der
geistigen Landesverteidigung begrüßen
aus 21 verschiedenen Schulen in Salzburg
in Zusammenarbeit mit der
Bildungsdirektion Salzburg
ein herzliches Grüß Gott aus der
Bildungsdirektion 5% der Bevölkerung auf
diesem Planeten leben in einer
Demokratie so wie wir die haben 45
weitere Prozentzahl quasi Demokratie und
der Rest der Kenntnis
ich glaube das ist ganz wichtig
in erster Linie im Kopf dieses
Bewusstsein was für ein hohes Gut die
Demokratie und die Freiheit in unserem
Land ist dieses Bewusstsein schwindet in
der Bevölkerung wir haben leider leben
müssen in den letzten Jahren wie
volatiles ist dass man wirklich in
Freiheit und Sicherheit leben darf der
Krieg in der Ukraine hat das gezeigt und
wir wissen auch dass neben der
militärischen Landesverteidigung auch
die wirtschaftliche die die
Landesverteidigung und vor allem auch
die geistige Landesverteidigung nicht
hoch genug einzuschätzen ist
[Musik]
ich unterrichte Geografie Geschichte
politische Bildung und Informatik
[Musik]
schon auszugewöhnlich
gemeinsam was machen will ja aus meiner
Sicht geht die umfassende
Landesverteidigung uns alle an das ist
also keine Aufgabe des Militärs hier
alleine der Vorreiter zu sein nur
gemeinsam können wir diese Aufgabe
unseren jungen Staatsbürgern das zu
vermitteln was Demokratie wer Wille
bedeutet unser Ziel ist in den Schulen
der Sekundarstufe 1 und Sekundarstufe 2
eine Referentin oder einen Referenten
für geistige Landesverteidigung zu
etablieren und das
Fortbildungskonzept dieser Menge dann
anzupassen so dass wir auch hier eine
gewisse Nachhaltigkeit erreichen
[Musik]